if you thought the hype for the MCU was
going to die down after Avengers in game
came out you may want to think again
how's it going everybody it's Warren and
as if phase four wasn't exciting enough
we still have the reveal of phase 5
coming up pretty soon and not only that
but the future of the MCU has never
looked more exciting considering the
fact that the Fantastic Four and the
x-men are coming to the MCU as well and
if all of that wasn't enough to get you
excited we now have reports saying that
Galactus himself is heading into the MCU
very soon and not only Galactus but
tyrant as well and possibly Marvel's
Ultimates so in this video I'll talk
about Galactus and tyrant entering the
MCU soon how we may even hear of
Galactus as early on as in the Eternals
how the Ultimates could be introduced
into the MCU and how Galactus could be
tied to them and where Galactus could
have been this whole entire time
throughout the MC use history I'll break
it all down in this video also if you
would like a chance to win an Xbox one
or a ps4 be sure to subscribe to my
channel like the video and comment below
with your favorite superhero or villain
so you can enter my giveaway I'll be
picking a winner at 500,000 subscribers
so today's report comes from MCU cosmic
MCU cosmic has leaked and has been write
about many MCU leaks in the past in fact
MCU cosmic was the first to report on an
Eternals movie beam in the process of
coming into the MCU and of course as we
know the Eternals was just announced for
phase 4 and last night MCU cosmic
announced that Galactus and tyrant are
going to be coming into the MCU soon the
report said with San Diego comic-con
over and the revelation of phase 4 many
think there's not much else planned for
the MCU not true at all they have all of
phase 5 planned out already and with the
Fox purchase Marvel has a lot of new
toys they've been waiting to play with
at some point in the near future Marvel
Studios plans to introduce the planet
eating Galactus as well as one of his
lesser-known creations tyrant Galactus
being introduced into the MCU is
something that many fans have been
waiting for for a really long time now
but doesn't really come as much of a
surprise fan OHS with the Infinity
Gauntlet and the Infinity stones was an
insanely powerful villain a villain that
took a
11 years to build up sure there are a
lot of powerful villains out there such
as Annihilus and Doctor Doom but not
many that could actually outdo thinness
with the Infinity Gauntlet and the
Infinity stones
however Galactus the Devourer of worlds
could definitely do the trick and he's
definitely somebody that could be built
up over the years as well much like
Thanos was Galactus over time has had
many different heralds which leads us
back to MCU cosmics report that tyrant
will also be introduced alongside of
Galactus if you're unfamiliar with who
tyrant is he was in the early 90s Silver
Surfer comic run Galactus is actually
the one who makes tyrant in his own
image and bestows upon him the power
cosmic tyrant serves Galactus until he
eventually gets his own desire for
conquest and then he rebels against
Galactus tyrant betrays Galactus and the
two of them enter into an epic cosmic
battle that results in some galaxies
being destroyed ultimately Galactus goes
on to defeat tyrant strips him of the
power cosmic and then banishes him into
deep space
now MCU cosmic also mentions to Galactus
his connections to the Celestials and
the fact that the Celestials are going
to be introduced in the Eternals
officially that is and we know that the
Eternals is going to take the future of
the MCU into the cosmos and they're
going to introduce the Celestials
because the Celestials are the ones who
created the Eternals and the deviance
and what we could end up seeing in the
Eternals is that tyrant could be the
very first Herald of Galactus the
Eternals would take place thousands of
years before the Silver Surfer was even
born
so this still leaves room for the Silver
Surfer to appear in the future of the
MCU as The Herald of Galactus still it's
not likely that we'll see Galactus and
the Eternals but we could see tyrant
Galactus probably won't be introduced
until years down the road and will most
likely be built up just the way they did
danos short clips of him here and there
may be some post-credit scenes until
ultimately he becomes the big bad
villain of the MCU MCU cosmic also
mentions Galactus his connections to the
Ultimates and how we have many of the
Ultimates in the MCU already The
Ultimates consist of Black Panther
Captain Marvel Monica Rambeau
blue Marvel American Chavez and Galactus
black panther Captain Marvel and Monica
Rambeau already exist in the MCU so they
would only have
introduce blue marvel American Java's
and of course Galactus the ultimate
storyline for Galactus would put a
different twist on his character it
would take him from being Galactus the
Devourer of worlds to Galactus the life
bringer he would go from destroying
planets to creating them which would be
an interesting storyline to see after he
was already the big bad and since
Galactus is such a huge villain the
question could be during this whole
entire time of the MCU and Thanos where
was Galactus of course there's always
the possibility that he was just simply
in another part of the universe
however Galactus is a being of extreme
power and he most likely knew that Fanus
was collecting all of the Infinity
stones and no matter who you are or how
powerful you are you are no match for
all of the Infinity stones together
Thanos wiped out half of all living
creatures in the whole entire universe
using the Infinity stones and the
Infinity Gauntlet
so perhaps Galactus was simply keeping
his distance from Thanos perhaps he was
waiting for Fanus to die before
devouring all of the plane that surround
Thanos not to mention he devours these
planets for their energy in order to
survive and the recent brothers confirm
that the Infinity stones aren't
necessarily gone they were simply
reduced to atoms they said that they
could come back so maybe Galactus is
seeking the Infinity stones for their
power now but wherever he was in the
universe and whatever reason we haven't
seen him yet everybody is really excited
about this news about Galactus finally
coming into the MCU so be sure to let me
know how excited you are for this to be
happening in the comments down below and
how do you hope go lactis is introduced
and again don't forget to comment with
your favorite superhero or villain like
this video and subscribe to my channel
so you can enter my giveaway and as
always thank you all so much for
watching wolf